the gods gave us many years
one day you'll know them all this is
where we keep them beautiful who Whitney
is
only the fierce the moment even could
and that is not you dying
you will train her harder than any
Amazon before her five times harder ten
times harder fail
never let your guard down you expect the
battle to be fair until she is better
than even you but she must never know
the truth about what she is
[Music]
[Applause]
what is this place who are you
it is our sacred duty to defend the
world where were you hard you are in
more danger than you think
be careful Diana no one else will defend
the wolf in a month welcome to jolly ol
London he's here yeah it's not for
everybody
or maybe not
is there anything else you enjoy
[Music]
I am gay an alchemist Kira daughter of
Hippolyta
in the name of all that is good feel
wrath upon this one is over
[Music]
Oh yep that's not going to work please
put the sword down it doesn't go with
the outfit at all
holy crap everybody do Wonder Woman
footage let's break it down the really
cool thing too is that a bunch of people
got to visit the Edit Bay Jeff jaws has
been helping edit the film they
explained about the first third of the
film so it has a lot of context for this
footage I'll try to explain it all but
I'm giving away new flash rings all you
have to do to enter is be subscriber
leave a comment on this video here we go
really badass look at the way her powers
work you only got like a taste of her
during Batman V Superman even though you
probably guessed before based on this
picture of the Louvre here she is
actually picking up in the opening
moments of the film right after the end
of Batman V Superman so there's sort of
like an unbroken line where Batman is
sending her this package with the photo
that she was trying to get from Lex
Luthor during that last movie the group
in the photo that shows up during the
trailer is sort of like this ragtag band
of people that she puts together that
are made up of allies that are trying to
take down the Danny Huston villain
characters plan so another a whole bunch
of questions about who he's playing who
Ares is in what's going on with this
doctor poison character here they
changed her name just a little bit but
she is confirmed as the doctor poison of
the movies so don't worry it all totally
works but it's basically a flashback
movie but you pick up in present day
then you flash back issues remembering
her childhood on temas Kyra so it's a
lot like Minas Tirith if you remember
the Lord of the Rings movies where it's
sort of built into the side of a
mountain but you pick up with her when
she's about eight years old in the way
they handle all the expository dialogue
you know this is who she is
these are who the gods are this is how
they figure into the world is through a
bedtime story which is a very movie
thing to do but you get a sense of the
majesty of feminists Kyra you meet some
of the important characters you learn
what happened to Zeus why he's not
around
why Ares is so bad why the Amazons
themselves were created with their
relationship with man is so I'll say
right off the bat David Thewlis is
confirmed as Ares but I'll explain him
in just a little bit so you see a bit of
a training montage here heard about 15
years old her she gets older there was
the teaser footage of her learning about
the gauntlet so she has this great power
that goes far beyond that of Amazon's
but they sort of skirt the issue about
how she's the daughter of Zeus and
Hippolyta for most of her life she only
knows that she's the daughter of
Hippolyta she doesn't know too
much about her purpose only that she
wants to be a warrior and recognizes the
threat of Ares was Steve Trevor enters
the story much much later but most of
her early life here is just spent trying
to become a badass just like the other
Amazon she sees around her so Robin
Wright Penn is playing Hippolyta sister
who trains her secretly because the
Paulito disallows it but jumping back
just to give it some more context so the
way they explained the Amazons and how
they exist in the world is it originally
Zeus created man to coexist with the
gods everybody was having a great time
Ares David Thewlis is character got
jealous so he turned man on himself the
gods intervened but in order to stop
that Ares started killing the other gods
Zeus created the Amazons to help fight
against Ares but Ares was able to use
man to enslave the Amazons eventually
Zeus using the god killer sword Wonder
Woman's sword that she has in all these
trailers I'll explain that in a second
uses that to gravely loot Ares but Ares
is able to kill Zeus with his dying
breath he creates Samus Kyra
so the Amazons can escape the slavery of
man and they hide out
so the Amazons hate man because they
were enslaved by that that explains why
they haven't helped out before and why
it's such a big deal with Steve Trevor
a man lands on their Island at the
beginning of World War 1 so that's when
you pick up with Wonder Woman as a child
Ares goes away you don't hear about him
till much later in the film when Steve
Trevor enters he crash-lands on sem
máscara he has secret plans that he's
stolen from the axis about a bioweapon
they're creating with his character here
the doctor poisoned character in Danny
Houston's character so they last him up
and you learn the story about what's
going on with world war 1 Wonder Woman
herself is horrified by this and feels
like Ares is behind adults his brand-new
gas weapon of mass destruction
so she agrees to help Steve Trevor
escape the island if he'll take her with
him so that she can kill Ares so that's
where you get to this scene right here
where she steals the god-killer sword it
is very literally a god killer sword
it's imbued with great power by Zeus and
steals her signature red blue and gold
uniform which was also presumably
by Zeus but they don't over explain why
it's that color and how it's more
special than other armor you should have
discovered that through the course of
the film but that's also where the
gauntlets come in - these are all God
created artifacts by Zeus left behind
after he died so Wonder Woman armored up
goes with Steve Trevor and that sort of
sets off the plot of the film where you
see them walking here through London you
see them running to edit candy a lot of
the other big Wonder Woman characters
from the comics they find out that the
Allies aren't super hot on trying to
stop this bioweapon either they don't
believe Steve Trevor that much - in the
way that the Amazons didn't want to help
out either so Steve Trevor's kind of an
outsider amongst man Wonder Woman is
also kind of an outsider amongst her own
people - so that brings them together
they form this ragtag group of people
that you see in the picture here the
black-and-white picture and they go on
the special mission to try and stop
Danny Houston's character but Wonder
Woman is also on a mission to try and
stop Ares Steve Trevor totally does not
buy into the idea of gods or any of this
crazy mystical stuff that Wonder Woman
is trying to sell them on so that's sort
of how they handle the mythology in the
film you just like most people don't
believe it till they see it so Ares is a
really weird character - you think he's
getting involved in world war one trying
to stir up trouble get man to kill
itself you kind of wonder what the most
effective way to do that is because he
wants to breed war so the interesting
thing is that he's playing this British
Lord so he's not wearing his armor for
most of the film there are parts of it
where you see the grand terrible Ares
and like the animated sequence when
they're telling the prehistory of Wonder
Woman before she herself was born and
through most of the film he's this
British Lord character masquerading is
an advisor to the Allies trying to push
everyone else into the war so like
imagine if America hadn't joined the war
imagine if Britain hadn't joined the war
so like a lot of the film takes place in
London Hill will probably show up in the
London sequences so that's sort of how
Wonder Woman sidesteps the problem that
a lot of superhero movies run into where
there's a big villain hero walks out
punches him in the face end movie it's
more that Ares is the guy behind the guy
sort of like a TF for the idea of dark
side in Steppenwolf so Steppenwolf comes
to earth in the Justice League movie
searching for the mother boxes
on the orders of Darkseid then you have
the Axis powers here developing this
weapon with the help of dr. Poisson in
Ares sort of pulling the strings on a
much grander scale like trying to get
whole countries to join the war so that
it will breed more war and make things
worse which is a crazy idea I love the
way they're dealing with history in this
but by that explanation this benefits
Ares so you know throughout all this you
have Wonder Woman and her small band of
people the film follows them around
through the second and third acts but
what I'm expecting is because you can't
tease Ares in a film like this and have
her bring the god-killer sword and all
her special zeus created armor and
weapons to try and take him down and
then not pay that off so there will be
some sort of confrontation with Ares
eventually but it'll be interesting to
see how the movie resolved his storyline
because in present day Wonder Woman has
sort of step back from humanity that was
the whole thing in Batman V Superman is
that she was coming back in taking a
more active role the implication is that
something at the end of Wonder Woman
that's really terrible happens and it's
probably going to be Steve Trevor's
death because just like Peggy Carter
Steve Trevor would have already died of
natural causes because remember this is
World War one so this is many years
before World War two you would have to
have some seriously good genetics to
survive that long let me know in the
comments though what do you think the
film is going to do with Ares at the end
because you can kill gods temporarily
but what happens when god die is that
new gods are born there's actually a
quote from a geoff johns comic book from
darkside war where they're able to kill
Darkseid but he's just reborn into
another form so the Wonder Woman comics
during the new 52 tried to address some
of that where Zeus is reborn as a baby
Wonder Woman has to care for him for a
brief period so killing the gods off
whether you're talking about Superman or
Zeus or anything else from the Wonder
Woman universe is just a way to create
dramatic tension because if you have an
all-powerful God available they can step
in at any time snap their fingers and
all your problems go away
it is a really big problem for
storytelling but congratulations to this
week's flash ring giveaway winner ninja
Ned 99 please private message me on the
back end of my channel so I can get your
contact details there was a new round
inserted in this video so I'll post a
new Guardians trailer video in a little
while that should be up in a couple
hours
well you a to that click here for
new Game of Thrones trailer and click
here to learn all about the black order
during infinity war thank you so much
for watching let's high pot I'll see you
guys in the next video
you